je lis régulièrement nos téléspectateurs
sur twitter parce qu'ils disent des
choses peuvent souvent très intéressante
et vous savez malheureusement je suis
tombé sur un sur un tweet d'une femme
qui visiblement n'a pas apprécié notre
première et qui visiblement est une
habituée des propos homophobes et qui a
réagi au baiser entre kelly et agathe et
qui a vu là une incitation à
l'homosexualité en raison du délit de
diffamation publique à raison de
l'orientation sexuelle
car désormais des critiquable tout acte
homosexuel peut être montré à la télé
devant les enfants
la propagande lgbt se poursuit en toute
laïcité sur toutes les chaînes
françaises
honteux alors on n'a pas voulu là sinon
je veux pas pour moi mais pour quoi
faire de pub je rappellerai simplement à
cette dame que il n'ya pas d'incitation
on est où on n'est pas aux deux choisit
pas et il n'y a pas de honte à ça voilà
exactement
alors on va voir le bisou entre agathe
équilibre il avait choqué mais
apparemment bien et c'est peu plus rogné
qu'on ait fait voilà je vous le dit dans
l'émission ghana où vous avez un petit
petites copines d'abord avant de revoir
celui d'agathe et kelly on vous a fait
une petite compil pour faire plaisir à
la dame ces nouveaux gardes comme c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu entre garçons entre
filles
voilà dans tpm p c'est d'abord une
petite compil et après pour le plaisir
on relève en direct à gâter québécois à
prendre fin en direct pour lui montrer
alors on refera tête on dirait que celui
d'agde attaques et dit merci à plat gâte
non
cela dit et plus
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
une homophobie totalement décomplexé sur
les réseaux sociaux faire parce qu'elle
est récidiviste
oui il dit et là nouveau elle peut tout
genre comme simple e mail pour moi soit
faire ce soir
agathe est d'accord aulas lors il avait
le samoa mélodies
je préfère qu'on n'incite à l'amour
plutôt qu'à la haine on se serait cru
dans ces cas là tu es attaquant pour le
plaisir pas le fait de la politique
[Applaudissements]
ma
ok